[Musique]
ils viennent de dizaines de pays
d'Afrique noire et ont tenté la
traversée du Sahara pour rejoindre
l'Algérie puis l'Europe
arrêter en Algérie et ensuite expulsé au
Niger certains sont coincés ici depuis
plus de 2 mois
des centaines de ces personnes arrivent
blessées au Niger ils accusent les
policiers Algériens de violence
on est en train de courir comme ça c'est
même qui est qu'ils ont tapé nous on a
tombé donc c'est eux qui a fait ça vous
comprenez on a eu les fractures sur mon
pied fracture avec mon ami là aussi vous
voyez la plupart sont enregistrés dans
un centre de transit prévu pour héberger
1000 personnes mais c'est au moins 2000
de plus qui demande l'aide de
l'Organisation internationale pour les
migrations à assamaka à la source du
problème le ralentissement des
rapatriements dû à la crise du covid-19
mais aussi aux expulsions régulières des
autorités algériennes dans des
conditions très dures au désert là
on nous a jetés à 4h du matin en plein
désert sans nourriture sans eau je
n'avais plus aucune force il tournait
autour de nous avec leur véhicule ils
tirait des coups de feu pour nous faire
fuir
après ce tournage nous avons contacté
l'ambassade algérienne suggère qui n'a
pas souhaité donner suite à notre
demande d'interview
[Musique]
quelques kilomètres plus loin en se
rapprochant de la frontière d'une un
lieu où à une époque seul les
transporteurs sera vitaaillés les
quelques commerçants présents sur le
site aujourd'hui sont régulièrement
témoin des arrivées en catastrophe de
groupe de personnes expulsées d'Algérie
ils ont souffert certains n'ont pas de
chaussures certains arrivent sans habits
quand ils arrivent ici ils ont déjà
beaucoup souffert le nombre de personnes
qui arrivent ici à augmenter avant on
avait 5 tentes aujourd'hui vous voyez de
vous-même chaque année le nombre de
personnes augmente
des opérations de sauvetage dans le
Sahara objectif éviter aux migrants
perdus dans le désert une déshydratation
mortelle
Ibrahim François part à la rescousse des
plus vulnérables sur son tricycle
le dernier convoi qui est arrivé il y a
sauté du véhicule il est tombé
du sang des oreilles de la bouche en fin
de compte les décennies il a été réussi
à
quand ils arrivent on leur donne ce
carnet pour qu'ils sachent quels sont
les dangers qui courent qu'ils en cours
sur la route
c'est au moins 30 personnes abandonnées
dans le désert par les autorités
algériennes qui ont perdu la vie au nord
d'assamaka depuis 2020
dans le nord du pays les centres de
transit de l'Organisation internationale
pour les migrations sont tous débordés
l'une des solutions pour les désengorger
et le retour volontaire dans le pays
d'origine mais une large partie des
procédures stagnent
on se retrouve avec une surpropulation
des bénéficiaires on pourrait dire que
on a généralement une manque de
ressources à la fois financière et aussi
du personnel pour assister ce nombre de
personnes
dans le centre de transit d'assamaka
surpeuplée depuis des mois certains
organismes humanitaires craignent la
propagation de maladies
on sait jamais quand est-ce que ça peut
arriver une épidémie et une épidémie
certaine maladie cancer arrive même si
c'est une seule personne c'est
préoccupant parce que ils sont très
proches ils sont très nombreux qui
vivent ensemble donc c'est là notre
préoccupation depuis le début de l'année
2022 le nombre de réfugiés sur le sol
nigérien a augmenté de près de 20%. au
30 octobre cela représentait près de 400
000 personnes les crises sécurité au
Mali au Burkina Faso et au Nigeria
continuel de pousser des milliers
d'individus à fuir vers le Niger